ans
et bien bonjour bonjour bienvenue
toujours avec le grand maître jean luc
chabanon bonjour bonjour stéphane pour
ce championnat du monde est le huitième
partie dernière partie dernière partie
donc l'ultime partie de ce match enfin
l'ultime alors qu'ils mènent ce camp
parce que laurence et 6,5 c'est
s'inquiète me chacun sait quoi
alors c'est ça qui est mis chacun donc
selon le règlement de la fidh
sinon il ya toujours cette histoire sur
la cinquième partie manquante donc mais
est ce qu'on retiendra de ce championnat
du monde le championnat demain des
toilettes je sais pas champion du monde
la suspicion est oui le championnat du
monde de la politique
on va dire le championnat du monde 2
des managers aussi puisque c'est quand
même c'est quand même le premier
championnat du monde où les joueurs
s'expriment par personne interposée
c'est quand même une grande première on
n'avait jamais vu ça auparavant on
considère maintenant que que le conte
dire que que la partie de conduire la
partie politique est là le jaune doit
pas intervenir dans ce côté là on
n'avait jamais vu ça puisque kasparov
karpov et fischer quand ils avaient leur
mot à dire ben il se gênait pas alors
est-ce que ça ressemble pas ce genre
d'affrontement avec manager et c'est ce
qui se passe dans l'image de boxe
justement oui c'est un petit peu ce qui
se passe dans les matchs de boxe
et puis ce qui se passe peut-être dans
le milieu fermé donc des grandes
disciplines sportives comme le football
où il ya des transferts il ya des
managers qui sont peut-être des hommes
de l'ombre mais qui interviennent
beaucoup dans la carrière de leurs deux
lors de leurs sportifs quoi alors par
rapport à la boxe leur territoire et un
site internet de photos chabat 9 ce qui
je crois oui oui où tu avais parlé de
l'oeil d'une pièce boxing nouvelle
discipline qui associe box et faire des
chèques donc le chessboxing ces deux
disciplines je voulais en parler un
petit peu puisque m ces pièces d'eau qui
fait partie de l'actualité le
chessboxing c'est une nouvelle
discipline qui a été inventé par un
artiste un artiste assez grandir assez
fantasque joueur enfin un artiste
hollandais qui habite à berlin et qui a
inventé donc cette discipline où on
mélange échec et boxe donc le
chessboxing une discipline qui inspirait
la bande dessinée de bilal voilà donc
quelques amis voilà au caire est aimanté
un peu ce concept voilà bilal qui avait
écrit de bande dessinée dans les années
80 froid équateur donc dans la trilogie
nikopol où il y avait donc des villages
c'est ce dessinateur qui nous fait des
pyramides ils volent dans le ciel avec
avec des dieux j'y tiens dedans exact
naissante sur terre est exactement bilal
qui aussi est devenu aussi un
réalisateur de film est actuellement en
train de tourner un film en asie je sais
plus exactement
donc voila et puis le chessboxing qui
sera bientôt bientôt à l'affiché en
france pour que damages prévu il ya un
match de démonstration prévue donc ça
c'est un gros scoop c'est que ça va tout
le monde veut y aller là c'est aussi
quand on veut y aller donc ça sera juste
un match de démonstration c'est pas un
match de compétition officielle mais
pour présenter les pièces boxing en
france donc ce match aura lieu donc
pendant le festival de la bande de la
science fiction à nantes
donc qui a lieu bientôt donc il y aura
il y aura du chessboxing donc alors donc
rounds de boxe et un blitz d'échec
exactement donc on commence plus tôt par
les échecs ont fait quatre minutes
d'échec
ensuite deux minutes de boxe et etc
jusqu'au 11e ronde
on a gagné si on met l'adversaire ou
s'il est ko et si on m'attaque pas si on
fait match nul sur l'échiquier
et si les packers et la même partie
qu'on joue tout au long du match
exactement exactement d'accord les
échecs aussi autant que soit ma tu sois
chaos
exactement c'est génial
c'est un petit peu c'est un petit peu ce
qui se passe actuellement donc taillé
liste a donc je crois que c'est soit 6,6
animat nini matnik à haut seuil haut
point c'est moi c'est celle arbitre
celle arbitres de la boxe qui décide
donc le vainqueur là c'est la porsche
qui va décider donc et puisque aux
échecs s'il ya match nul ya match nul
voilà donc on compte pas aux déchets
qu'ils n'ont pas du tout l avantage ou
quoi que ce soit et j'ai assisté donc il
ya un an un championnat d'europe de
chasse boxing gagné par un bulgare donc
les bulgares qui sont très présents aux
échecs et autres choses boxing et les
noms donc alors un super discipline
alors peut-être que après ce match
kramnik et topalov vont se faire un
match et ce boxing pour se départager
ce serait salmagne j'imagine que j'ai
envie de frapper enfin surtout chronique
je pensais là j'imagine que les joueurs
comme la sont assez tendus alors 12e et
dernière partie du match kramnik à
l'eiblen aux dernières parties avec les
blancs pour crâner s'ils l'emportent et
bien c'est tout de suite il est champion
du monde il y aura les y aura pas de
discussion possible
et en cas de match nul est bien il a
accepté de toute façon de jouer jusqu'au
tie break sous protestation par rapport
à la cinquième partie donc kramnik doit
gagner pour pour pour devenir champion
du monde est contestable et et en cas de
nul il aura donc il y aura tie break
malgré le fait évidemment qu'il a perdu
une partie par forcer mais bon c'est la
règle qu'il a accepté de jouer sous
protestation qu'est ce que ça veut dire
je suis d'accord mais je suis pas
d'accord en fait c'est un peu ça la
chronique se protège
oui puis il garde une carte
supplémentaire gardant dans sa poche de
plus on voit tout de suite faire dans la
partie on vous allez voir qui a été
superbe
je crois qu'elle est allée super
positionnelle cette partie c'est pas une
partie à sacrifices oui donc là c'est le
grand jeu le grand jeu positionnelle
encore une fois et puis on va voir si
elle est à l'étude
c'est une partie qui est pur je pense
qu'il ya aucune faute dans cette sortie
je crois qu'on n'a pas noté à aucun
moment on a noté de fautes dans cette
partie on va dire quand même qu'il ya eu
des imprécisions de la part des noirs
quelque part mais aussi après les blancs
auront rattrapé mais toujours sur le fil
quoi mais c'est clair si jamais c'est la
version qui sont collés quand même ces
deux partis a suivi un un chemin presque
presque parfait c'est clair c'est que
l'armée les noirs étaient garées sous
pression c'est factuel et non ont dû
trouver des ressources
voyons ça tout de suite on va voir ça
tout de suite alors classique dans ce
championnat du monde
une slave après des quatre des cinq ses
cadres ses 6 on est toujours en une
slave cavaliers f3 kabylie et 6 hélas
peu 3 voilà donc le classique maintenant
avec couleurs inversées avec couleurs
inversées
alors dans les matchs de championnat du
monde en général c'est un petit peu
différent ça s'est passé un petit peu
différemment souvent puisque quand
kasparov à l'époque kasparov temps
qu'elle était et est la star il y avait
les stades yens et karpov lui ne jouais
pas l'espagne m là où les indiens de me
le rappeler six mois les blocs mans avec
g6 et fou j'ai cette voie là et là on a
deux joueurs qui jouent exactement les
mêmes d'ouverture donc c'est un duel de
spécialistes c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment moi ces miroirs contraignant
voilà ces miroirs contre miroir c'est je
comprends mieux la position que toi
c'est moi c'est pour ça qu'ils se
chamaillent se chamaillent sur la
compréhension de la volaille se rendre
la pareille 2
de partir mardi puisque là je crois que
ça fait ça fait deux trois parties ont
débuté par les 17 premiers coups de
cette partie trois parties dans les
quatre dernières alors on va voir la
suite fouere 5 cavale et ses 3 au 6
c'est la même que jouer topalov à sa
chronique à la partie d'avant donc c'est
un fait incroyable que les joueurs
choisissent exactement la même ouverture
cavailles hcap toujours classique on
veut échanger se fout là on avait déjà
parlé il faut jessica va les prendre
donc on va pas revenir sur les
commentaires qu'on a pu faire dans les
parties précédentes vous invite à avoir
donc h pranger 6 g iii et maintenant
alors j'ai trois déjà c'est un petit
changement évidemment puisque la
topaloff avait joué soit à 3 soit tour b
1 voilà donc là c'est le coup on dirait
hyper classique le coup classique le
cook que j'ai annoncée dans les parties
précédentes
on appelle la théorie quoi la théorie la
théorie la nouveauté poisson
n'est pas au rendez vous g 3g trois
cavaliers b17 food et 2 voilà donc fou
des deux encore une fois les joueurs on
évite donc ce qui a été le coût
principal cette année temps c'est à dire
fou g2 ils veulent avec une perte du
pian ces cas-là il préfère attendre un
petit peu la décision d des noirs avant
de passer avant de développer le fossé
style de kramnik de d'essayer de
ne pas donner à touba l'offre des
dépositions asymétrique où il peut faire
exprimez-vous peut exprimer son talent
d'attaquants mais plutôt d'avoir des
positions ou chronique à infléchir
avantage c'est son style sa légère
avantages durables
oui et puis en plus il n'y a pas envie
de répéter quelques pas répéter mission
il veut pas répéter ce qui était jeu
dans le match
d'autant plus que dans la dernière
partie donc dans la 11e il a quand même
montré avec les noirs une bonne faute
une bonne façon pour pour défendre tout
à fait donc ils testent topalov sur un
autre terrain alors fou b4 voilà donc
fou des cadres peut-être échangé ce
cavalier pour mieux contrôler les quatre
centrales exactement donc topalov qui
décide d'emmener trois logicil de donner
la paire de fou tout là tout de suite
évident s'attaque le fouet par
transparence le pion bessette sachant
qu'après derrière aussi le pion c6
serait emprise donc les n'auront pas
trop le choix en fait ils peuvent même
pas protéger le fou par à 5 de tanks ou
comme d'hab b6 peut-être d'un v6 oui
peut-être mais montsûrs d'un v6
peut-être qu'elle y perdrait des temps
il y aurait un coût comme com
ces cinq peut-être qu'avec un v6 va y
perdre du temps sur la variante ces cinq
là mais n'aurait pas utilisé topaloff
je pense que dans la 11e enfin dans la
wii dans le nom d'allah oui c'est ça
mais c'est ça la 11e effectivement pas
tout à l'heure et à la 11e alors dam des
trois fours en c3 et l'a donc kramnik
reprend du fou évidemment puisqu'il en
reprenant un des pions il aurait bloqué
son fou il aurait un peu voilà donc à
ses fils y est fan et qui a cette fois
la paire de fou mais contre deux
cavaliers nous on avait vu pour
l'instant dévoiler des matchs père de
foucauld fouet cavaliers maintenant ses
pairs de fou contre deux cavaliers
sachant que les deux cavaliers bon mais
s'en sort bien quand il ya encore pas
mal de pions et que la pollution et
complexes ce qui est le cas voilà la
pression des gouvernements sans la
pression est fermé là ils s'en sortent
puisqu'ils peuvent sauter facilement sur
les cases des cases un peu un peu un peu
esseulé ça devient plus compliqué pour
eux évidemment si la position devient
très ouverte cavaliers aux quatre donc
la logique si on a échangé ce cas
valises ici en ses transes était
justement pour pouvoir sauter sur cette
case ou cadres aux cavaliers ou quatre
qui un coût important aussi puisque
environ 130 voilà bohain beaucoup de
cabaye au centre c'est important
beaucoup de cas liés au centre et un
coup vraiment temps que le pion bessette
étant prise alors le pion bessette et
emprise est donc là j'ai analysé un
petit peu cette position alors voyons
qu'est ce qui se passe et ça donne donc
lieu à une variante assez assez
intéressante donc voilà donc maintenant
juste une petite voilà donc aller
directement sur le coût d'un prend 17
faire baisser la donc d'appréhender
cette là les noirs jouent tourbe et 8
pour attaquer la dame
donc on attaque la dame donc l'on a le
choix soit de prendre le pion à 7 soit
le pion sait si ce soit de revenir à 6
voilà donc on a plusieurs possibilités
si on qui est logique c'est pendant ce
mois là ce qui est logique c'est de
prendre le pion qui ont le plus proche
du centre voilà hélas les noirs ont dû
contre jeu de différentes manières ils
peuvent jouer soit dames et six dans
cette position donc de même si ce qui
est intéressant pour attaquer le pion f2
le pion f doit avancer puisqu'en menace
quand même dame prend f2 suivi chez
échec le roi serait des rockets et il y
aurait joué f4 oui il faudrait jouer f4
et là on pourrait peut-être jouer
cavalier pranger 3 qui sera intéressant
cavaliers projetteront la de cahiers
projet trois énormes puisque la tour ici
empêche le pion de bougies à cause de la
tour blanche
voilà donc ça c'est peut-être une
possibilité mais il ya aussi un autre
coup qui est possible un autre coup que
des médecis s'il revient en arrière un
très joli coup c'est le coutour prend b2
tout simplement tour prendre b2 alors
toutes tombées très surprenant ah oui un
tour pro d2 qui est un coup magnifique
puisque là si on prend la tour avec le
four en c3 maintenant il ya damas cinq
échecs
voilà damas cinq échecs dans la soirée
chèque
voilà alors sur le royaume lui romain
donc qui attaqué par la dame s'en voit
qu'on peut pas mettre de pièces sur mais
le fou ça change rien puisqu'ils
auraient dame prend four exactement
l'ordre un fou pour rien le roi s'il
vient sur la case d1 il ya dam des deux
échecs et mat
il m'a tout de suite c'est la partie
difficile cavaliers protège adam
on voit tout simplement c'est le fameux
baiser de l'amant jean-luc exactement le
fameux baiser de la mort qu'on enseigne
aux enfants et aux débutants donc un
math l'internement euros et demi et
c'est le baiser d'amour et sinon il ya
matt aussi sinon bonjour 2 voilà donc il
ya un baiser de la mort
plus compliqué un peu plus long on joue
d'am dam des deux rois f3 échec donc là
le seul coup on va fuir c'est de fuir en
f3 n'y a pas d'autres coups voilà la
dame qui vient prendre le pion sur et
maintenant on peut prendre deux encore
puisque le cas les pros tels on voit que
le roi ça y est il est aux fraises
n'étant plus que ce que la touriste il
empêche toute façon de venir sur six
cases là donc il n'a plus qu'une seule
case le port varois
et là il ya 3 va être possible et là il
ya plein de monde possible puisque le
roi tout simplement il n'a pas de gaz
bon alors que la sepri par le cavalier
là ici tout ça est pris par la dame
et tout ceci ici est pris par la tour
dont suffit de faire un échec et seimat
voilà donc on peut vous sais pas si on
peut faire donc des médecins coup ou f5
donc d'un même sens que c'est plus
simple on va faire le vrai baiser la
mort donc on peut faire d'alleurs f5
échec et mat
on peut faire aussi cavalier un peu
patrick louis pardon et on peut faire f
voilà donc sachez le climat ça fait deux
matches ça fait 2-1 possible et sinon on
peut aussi faire traîner on peut faire
cavalier six échecs encore on peut
toujours faire traîner dans cette
position est drôle et 5 et au courage
c'est une matière aux sandales choix ça
c'est un choix artistique exactement un
prêt du joueur tu préfères moi j'aime
bien les maths qui met en joue le
maximum de pièces
je trouve ça plus jolie là donc c'est
vrai que ça met en jeu le cavalier la
tour j'aime bien les mettre avec des
petites pièces aussi c'est vrai qu'à
remettre avec un pion c'est quand même
c'est joli et très jolie variante
analysé ici donc cavalier e 4 donc
d'apprendre et d'apprendre 17
probablement très risqué donc on l'a vu
que c'était très risqué donc le kramnik
rentre pas là dedans on vient de voir
les possibilités donc tout simplement
fou j'ai deux fous j'ai 2 tout
simplement on évite de rentrer dans les
variantes que topaloff avait sans doute
analysé jusqu'au bout et chroniques
aussi sans doute
sa serai peu ça serait très étonnant que
kramnik ne connaissent pas cette
possibilité lundi qui rend le fou donc
qui décide de rendre le full
immédiatement dans sa position et de
rendre ce fou ces trois voilà donc là
cette fois il faut le prendre quand même
il faut pas laisser la paire de faux
jouer donc cavale et pensaient
travailler pour son projet fou pour
éviter peut-être fou b4 un suivi de f3
correspond à l'arrivée exactement donc
allez prends ces trois dames français
trois ont reprendre la dame et on va
voir qu'après f5 bien là déjà tout de
suite cramique a un choix à faire qui
est pas évident oui alors donc f5 qui
pose une qui pose d'une structure de
pions donc c'est important de regarder
la structure de pions des noirs puisque
elle porta non donc lorsqu'on a donc jeu
juste noirci un mur de pierre voilà
c'est ce qu'on appelle donc le stonewall
donc on utilise secondes on se mouille
l'est qui veut dire murs de pierre donc
lorsqu'on a cette structure de pions au
centre qui contrôle très très bien le
une couleur qui vont très bien les cases
blanches
on a ce qu'on appelle
un stonewall voilà donc et topalov douce
au stonewall dans cette position parce
qu'il a peur qu'à n'importe quel moment
cram unique et poussent le pion aux 3 e
4 il veut pas que krainik vous faire le
singe voilà il a peur de ce que le pian
et enlève cette chronique peut ouvrir la
position pour son fou qui alors ce
serait supérieur aux cavaliers voilà
donc dans cette position il fait un an
l'ue et le bloc
il fait un mur de pierre finalement face
aux fous j'ai 2 donc on peut dire que
kramnik oblige topalov à jouer
positionnelle en fait ils l'obligent à
jo positionnelle il oblige encore à ne
pas se développer pour contrôler le
centre donc un petit coup de
développement qui va être utile puisque
par la suite comme nick va quand même
avoir une certaine initiative
alors là il y avait un choix pour
kramnik c'était de jouer grand roc ou
petit rock ou attendre parce que le
problème c'est que la tour ici quand
même tape un peu sur le plus rage 2 bon
ça peut être un thème d'attac
ça peut être un thème d'attac maroc
n'avait l'air avait l'air tout à fait
jouable grand roque avait l'air tout à
fait jouable mais il faut voir une chose
c'est pour cette position travnik doit
faire un plan sur le long terme et en
faisant grand roque sans plan sur le
long terme
son action au centre elle n'est pas
vraiment défini en faisant petit rock
son action stratégique est beaucoup plus
défini donc s'il avait fait grand roque
sans doute que cravic aurait dû jouer
pour une rupture au centre ici un cas
donc je et f3 et f4 voyez ce qui est et
ce qui était plutôt maladroit puisqu'il
y avait un fond g2 donc mettre le fou
derrière tous les pions c'est plutôt
maladroit il aurait été mal positionné
ce foot voilà donc alors qu'en faisant
petit rock c'est ce qu'a fait crâne y
voilà c'est à dire faisant le coup de
crâne ni qu'on se rend compte que
finalement la taxe sur la sueur h pour
l'instant elle est loin d'être d'être
évidente alors ça fait peur quand même
parce qu'on pourrait se dire tout
simplement dame et saint damase 6 et mat
et mat
oui mais
les blancs ont largement le temps de
défendre maginot d'alger cents donc il
n'a pas été joué alors ces cas là la
stratégie d'eads et blanc et sa
stratégie des blancs est tout simplement
d'attaqué de l'autre côté donc soit de
pousser bécade soit des échanges et des
genres des cinq de jouer les 2 4 et
en-cas imaginons b4 par exemple si la
table vient sur hadji menace nat
bon là on peut tout simplement poussé le
plan d'une case on joue simplement h3 et
en cas de geci g5 g4 on peut jouer
encore h4 on a le temps on a le temps et
on va quand même ouvrir au centre et à
l'est la dame et aussi on va enlever sa
tour émettre le roi sur la case f1
exactement devront éviter aux dares de
maths
voilà qu'on mettra le roi tranquillement
à l'abri le fou empêchant des manoeuvres
compliqué exactement
donc après donc après le coup petit rock
on va revenir donc après le coup petit
rock pour les blancs petit rock
l'idée des blancs maintenant c'est
important c'est de faire ce que l'on
appelle donc la tacc allèles dame donc
la taxe qui pourrait être une attaque
une attaque
de minorités fameuse attaque démérité
mais pour l'instant on
on voit pas parlé directement de
minorité pense encore voir on va voir ce
que la minorité n'existe pas pour
l'instant pas encore mais l'idée
principale c'est de jouer b 4 des 5
c'est de jouer des 4b 5b d'ouvrir belles
dames d'ouvrir et d'essayer de casser
cette structure depuis on avait joué
contre cette structure en s'aidant du
fonds
voilà donc en s'aidant du fou donc
combiner l'action des pions c4 et
éventuellement bessac par le par
l'action du fou j'ai 2 alors on va vous
riez ouvrir les voir ce que je veux
topalov donc déjà il a joué dans le set
il a bien vu que ça n'attaque dame g5 et
d'un mach 6 était simplement contrer il
aurait ensuite eu deux pièces un peu
hors jeu voilà ils préfèrent seul et
préférait garder un coup un peu plus
stable au centre et après maintenant
crâne et joue très simple c'est là qu'on
voit que des fois les coups les plus
simples morin sont les plus forts
exactement chronique qui qui crée sa
propre minorité et se crée sa minorité
on va voir tout de suite après s'éprend
des 5
eh bien il faut reprendre du pillon eux
parce que si on reprend du pian c'est
évidemment on donne on donne tout
simplement la colonne ouverte voilà on y
est maintenant doubler les pièces sur
cette colonne on va envahir le camp noir
par ces sept tonneaux mètres la tour
eiffe je pense que l'on peut même mettre
l'autre tour effectivement faire c'est
le choix des le fameux choix des tours
je détourne là ça permettrait aux fous
de sortir plus vite donc il faut prendre
des pions et maintenant voilà on a ce
qu'on appelle les minorités pourquoi
minorité parce qu'ici voyez on a trois
pions 4 même quatre avec celui ci contre
trois et on a un deux trois ici voilà
alors ce qui est intéressant d'expliquer
c'est pourquoi pourquoi on appelle ça
une attaque d'une minorité quel est
l'intérêt d'attaqué avec trois pièces
contre 4 ça c'est quand même une grande
question et c'est donc après la réponse
donc la réponse est simple c'est que
dans cette position quand on joue
imaginons que l'on pousse le pion ici
oui et qu'on le pousse la vrai qu'on le
pousse sur les faces b 5 pions avance
ici et là oui dans cette position on va
donc on risque d'attaquer le pion 6,6 en
attaque le pion c6 voilà qui va du coup
cela revêt un peu et stable ont mené
sera tout simplement donc d'échanger ses
pions celui ci donc contre le pion 17 et
après le processus va se retrouver tout
seul ariélès un défenseur ça va être une
cible
ça va être une cible ce sera le seul
pion en plus mais un pion qui ne peut
pas avancer puisqu'il sera bien bloqué
et et qui va être constamment attaqué
une fois que le pire arrive en bessin
qu'il ya un autre cas de figure c'est
que ce pion prennent en b 5
dans ces cas là il y aurait une pièce
qui vais reprendre en bessin et qu'ils
attaqueraient à la fois ce pion ce pion
sur 17 élus puis en allant vers la
colonne sait et on aurait ouvert la pub
est affaibli et affaiblit effectivement
ce fameux pions ici des cinq qu'on leur
a affaibli c'est clair voilà l'idée la
tad l'attaquent 2000 ont été ses
classiques contre une structure de ce
type là voilà eh bien on peut avec deux
pions ici il faut d'ailleurs très
souvent c'est le plan faute accablé on a
moins de deux pions que les autres que
les autres mais on attaque une structure
figée par une structure dynamique
exactement donc je ne sais pas
exactement depuis quand cette attaque de
minorités existe mais on peut se dire on
peut dire que dans les années dans les
années 50 les meilleurs joueurs du monde
donc ce pasky tu allais tous a développé
la théorie sur cette voie la paix rhdp
cian tout ça donc on joué beaucoup de
tact de minorité
et ont quand même montré que c'était
quelque chose d'extrêmement dangereux
même avec peu de pièces comme comme dans
cette position alors on va voir toutes
les chroniques et mais il perd pas de
temps c'est là qu'on voit que c'est très
très clair le jeu de k granic est
limpide dans cette partie il ya une
structure de pions super super solide
super scène ici petit affaiblissement du
côté noir et les noirs vont prendre ici
sur ces camions une attaque de l'autre
côté par ses pions là il va falloir que
topalov ajouté extrêmement précis alors
b4 et voilà tout de suite et bien
kramnik peu menacé b5 au prochain coup
même à cette réflexion peut pas l'homme
joue cavalier m6 logique
il veut maintenant venir sur la case de
4 il veut venir sur la case de guy
boucher se fout exacte de ce fou
d'autant plus puissant évidemment qu'ils
tapent sur des simples puisque quand on
joue b5 tout de suite bien le pion à des
scènes n'est pas en prise parce qu'il y
aurait fou prend pions des 5 avec l'
avantage puisque on aura un pion central
passé ce qui est énorme comme avantage
donc tout et c'est un autre ami qui
prend son temps qui fuit de trani
puisque l'asse pièce avant que je vais 5
évidemment si je vous décerne tout de
suite on peut prendre b 5 puisque
maintenant le cavalier aussi se protège
des 5 même si c'est un peu faible
oui on le sent un peu fait mais c'est
jouable mais surtout on va jouer al sisi
on va on va défendre ce prix après on va
jouer à six mois là c'est donc c'est
quand même joué donc ça c'est pas facile
kramnik prend son temps il joue d'abord
tours fc un cavalier ou 4 donc logique
maintenant topalov joue parfaitement la
défense ils bloquent l'action de ce fou
qui était quand même extrêmement bien
conjuguer avec une attaque de minorité
puisque il attaque les cases blanches et
là en jouant carioca très bien ils
bouchent la manière de ce fou on a
adressé à ses essentiels qu'avait lieu 4
qui comme un coup on va dire essentielle
et fort un coup important oui et puis un
coup qui a 70 ans pour une raison un
petit peu géométriques
c'est qu'on remarque vaut quelque chose
qui n'a pas vraiment de rapport avec
on pourrait dire par superstition quoi
il y avait quand même un côté topalov a
dit d'ailleurs qu'il était pas
superstitieux mais en jouant cavalier e
4 il y à il ya un aspect superstition
dans ce coup c'est que on a un vrai on
avait dans cette position si on regarde
bien donc on a on a là dans cette
position 1 v qui est très curieux donc
qui est assez rare avec ses pièces oui
jolivet ou un joli triangle
voilà donc on a un joli vais donc
topaloff dans cette dernière ronde fait
le fameux v de la victoire
alors est ce que c'est un bon si nous un
mauvais signal on va voir si la dernière
partie de la soirée à lire pour
l'instant mais c'est sûr que là ça peut
ça peut être effectivement ça peut être
un signe ça peut être ainsi que le
bulgare va réussir à nous refaire le
coup de gagner cette partie est légal et
noir publié a bien précisé qu'il n'était
pas superstitieux il n'est pas
superstitieux dame b2 donc logique de
kramnik donc ils enlèvent la dame
évidemment qui est attaqué par le
cavalier sur la case b2 puisqu'ils
gardent un oeil peut-être sur la kf2 qui
est quand même attaqué par le cavalier
ce qui a conjugué avec la tour h 8 qui
attaquent age ii pourrait donner des
idées au noir donc sans doute la dame
b2c un coup aussi un peu défensif en
même temps d'un bep 2 qui prépare
surtout b5 et qui prépare b5 en même
temps mais il aurait pu aussi jouer dans
b3 voilà qui était un autre coup la b3
ou voire même trois padam détroit qui
aussi protège enfin prépare aussi b5
d'un bep 2 est en même temps un tout
petit peu défensif sans doute sur la
case m2 donc on sait jamais on est pliée
quand même une chose importante quand on
joue tmb 2 par rapport à dam des trois
c'est que souvent quand on a joué à
quatre et bill 5 ou quand on a ouvert
ici on est quand même contents d'avoir
des pièces lourdes sur les
sur les colonnes à b et c a cédé pour
entrer dans le camp ennemi exactement
partout et par tous les chemins
donc c'est pour ces raisons qu'il a
placé la dame sur b2 je pense alors
petit rock d'autoblog maintenant donc ça
y est donc ses classiques on le voit
dans cette position où le fou g6 a été
changé malgré le fait qu'on nous la
colonne h dans aucune partie
on a vu les noirs réussir à tirer profit
de cette colonne exactement
donc parce que ses pions l'a sans doute
empêche les les pièces de basculer
facilement et de créer de vraies menaces
quoi alors bessaih maintenant kramnik
c'est leur twitter je menace tout
simplement qu on prend des six et qui
ont promené cynisme et tout reprend
pions alors évidemment ça pose tout de
suite un problème en noir sur cette case
et puis on prend mes 5 semble hors sujet
puisque tout simplement dame prend b5
pose déjà des problèmes puisque le pion
et attaquer tout de suite donc ce pion
va être une faiblesse difficile à
défendre
donc après b5 topalov défend tout
simplement avec sa tour puis on prend
ces six donc là il fait pas de détail
chronique 1 il y va quoi c'est si
limpide c'est direct il est il est mieux
et quand même un peu mieux crâne et
qu'il a il al'avantage de d'espacement
qui s'ouvre la colombe et maintenant il
ouvre cette colonne donc apprécié en
france et 6 taupe avait choisi de ne pas
échanger de tour s car c'est un bon
calcul
quand on en défense il vaut mieux éviter
des changes et les tours puisque les
finales de tours sont souvent nul mais
je pense que aussi topalov dans sa
position sa tour et fuite il aimerait
bien enfin il a envie de il a envie
d'avoir un peu d'activité il a une
colonne h ouverte
alors peut être veut il veut peut être
activée cette tour voilà je voulais un
f6 par exemple jouer g5 et ensuite jouer
la tour sur la cage h6 par exemple
attaquer le club de on va voir
d'ailleurs que ça effectivement
c'est un peu l'idée de tout pas là donc
il ya du tour ici défensive qui
ti paul qui donc tient bien la casse et
6 et il veut faire jouer sont sans
compter que si si topaloff avait pris de
la tour ans et 6 donc après des princes
ici surtout processus pour francis les
blancs ne sont pas obligés des changes
les tours ils peuvent aussi jouer un
coup comme d'hab b5 ou d'un bep trois
dames b3 droite inquiète pour dessein
qui attaque de suite l'option v5
effectivement oui si axa met lass a mis
l'accent sur la faiblesse des cinq qui
est essentiel parce que si cette 6e puis
on saute c'est tout la position nord qui
saute
à noter qu'il ya aussi un clouage non
sur l'europe donc c'est toujours
embêtant effectivement donc qu'en france
et si ce plan français 6 et dam de mes
talents kramnik joli petit coup ici
dames 2 ça me donne un coup de coude
traversent ou un peu long qui en fait un
oeil sur la case à 6 voilà donc il a un
oeil sur cette case puisqu'ici en a6 la
dame sera très très bien placé puisque
elle attaquera la fois à cet essai 6
tout en contrant à la casse bessette qui
peut être en jouant par exemple tombé à
1 tour 17
une classe de pénétration d'où l'idée de
ce coup oui l'idée l'idée c'est de
libérer la colonne b pour la tour il
veut effectivement les jours ici
éventuellement donc quand il ajouté m 2
c'est tout simplement pour pouvoir
défendre son pion à deux en même temps
aussi puisque si l'adversaire sur la
case avec la dame noire sur la case à
troyes il faut quand même garder une
case de défense voilà donc la cage de 2
à un coût qui permette d'être un petit
peu les dames et un peu les droits
j'essaye de topalov seller donc là
maintenant topal suisse se réveille et
d'ailleurs il faut pas qu'ils attendent
passivement en jouant g5 pas le veut
poser maintenant des problèmes sur le
roi blanc qui pour l'instant est
tranquille surtout quand on est attaqué
en général comme ça sur le roi il faut
éviter de bouger sur soi-même les pions
est-ce que c'est donner des coups pour
se faire battre
oui exactement donc j'ai 5 il veut sans
doute immobilisé par g4 ici complètement
sûr cases blanches immobilisé les blancs
ou alors peut-être pourquoi pas aussi
jouer la rupture f4 puisqu'il ya une
tour derrière on peut jouer le coup f5
et cadres alors après sur ab1
quand même l'impression que tous peuvent
pêcher en eaux troubles dans cette
position ils essayent ils essayent
parent de s'activer
mais il est logique ce coup on va le
voir tout de suite bon alors tout de
suite par contre f4 n'est pas possible
pourquoi pas ce qu ont tout simplement
prendre et du pion aux yeux et on voit
que le cavalier maintenant est clouée
sur la dame c'est une gaffe direct donc
après une reprise tout simplement la
joie f3 et on gagne on gagne un cavalier
f3 et lecavalier et pris puisque si
bouge
évidemment c'est la dame qui se prive
donc tour à bien et donc topalov ne peut
pas jouer ça et donc joue dans le 17ème
17 donc un joli coup topalov une
tranquille encore un tout petit coup
mais en fait tout simplement il enlève
déjà le vis-à-vis des dames et peut-être
menaces émanant f4 leur envie de jouer
4 il a peut-être envie de jouer ce cadre
ça sera toujours pas possible puisque le
cavalier lecavalier sera en prise mais
sûr puisque après f4 qui on prend un f4
et le fouet la dame attaque fait
cavalières et cavaliers ensuite et on
reprendrait de la dame donc maintenant
cramique joue le coutour c2 alors là un
petit coup un petit coup de tours alors
l'idée de ce genre de coup c'est bon à
la fois déjà si on fait une défense
quand même traverse traverse mais aussi
on peut doubler les tours par exemple
sur la colonne c'est ou alors même sur
la colonne b avec une pénétration en 17
voilà le genre de possibilités que qu'à
la démocratique donc logique écologique
où il veut doubler les tours sont
doublés les tours très important tf6
donc ça y est on pas l'homme donne le
plan qu'on donnait tout à l'heure il
défend à la fois ces six coups défensifs
et en même temps il peut passer sa tour
en justice
revenant sur la colonne âge pour faire
pression cette fois en étant aidé par
deux pions qui peuvent servir de bélier
paraître 4 ou éventuellement par g4 pour
mobiles
et les blancs tour baissé 1,2 kramnik
qui augmente la pression est maintenant
sur ses six métiers et si c'est pour
l'instant très bien défendu 1 2 3 et on
n'a que deux attaquants il faudrait
quatre attaquants donc on est très loin
du compte
exactement et l'as templeuve joue g4
voilà ils l'empêchent peut-être les
blancs d'avoir des plans à base de f3 et
f4 donc ça y est ce qu'à valider
délogeables lecavalier donc est installé
sur la case de 4 voilà donc ça c'est le
bon côté des noirs ils ont beau cavalier
au centre c'est à dire que là on peut on
peut considérer que la structure de
pions noirs
même si à cette petite faiblesse en c6
quand même contrôler parfaitement se
fout g2 qui est dans l'impossibilité
s'exprimer on peut dire que la défense
de todo topaloff est archi positionnelle
oui tout à fait et là avec les quatre
ans on empêche définitivement une
rupture puisque cette rupture est tout
simplement elle sera échangée et on va
d'ailleurs que le pion g7 remplacera
facilement à son collègue son collègue
après pour la suite tour b2 maintenant
kramnik bien bizarrement maintenant on
va choisir de revenir sur la colonne des
donc on se demande pourquoi il n'a pas
fait tout de suite finalement si on
revient un peu en arrière
pourquoi jouer tour ces deux est pas
tombé 2 finalement si c'est pour revenir
un peu sur la même sur la même colonne
non je pense que dans un premier temps
cramique avaient l'intention de
provoquer g4 est maintenant de vous
tomber et de revenir après sur la
colonne puisque
une fois que le plus rêver à avancer sur
g4 il ya des bons côtés pour les noirs y
a plus il y avait il n'y a plus la
poussette canne ya plus poussées 4 ou
alors faudrait rejouer j'essaye mais qui
affaiblirait un peu le rendement un peu
beaucoup il donc bon on en sait que si
je t'écoute attentes mais pas vraiment
ce dock ou d'attentes exactement
tourache 6 donc ça y est il y vient
topaloff il continue de protéger sa case
c6 et commence à faire une petite
pression sur age 2 qui commença pas être
négligeable parce qu'il ya quand même le
cavalier qui contrôle les deux il ya
quand même les pions ici qui sont sur le
côté
donc ça commence à devenir quand même un
tout petit peu menaçants pour l'europe
de kramnik mai mais évidemment la
pénétration de kramnik du côté dames
peut largement compensé cette cette
menace parce que c'est le roi noir qui
risque lui aussi d'être soit ensuite
sous la le feu des pièces blanches
alors j'ai juste un petit point à
préciser un tout petit un coût plutôt
donc un truc amusant c'est que là dans
cette position au lieu de tourbe et 2
donc prêt g4 ya le coup il ya le coutour
b1 donc qui pourrait être intéressant
qui a été proposé par pas mal de
spécialistes donc j'y reviendrai voilà
de revenir après avoir provoqué le
coucher 4 donc il n'y a pas beaucoup de
différence
mais il se trouve qu'une vingtaine de
coups plus tard il y en a une à une
vingtaine de groupes d'accord c'est
assez compliqué c'est mais si on
considère après la suite à la partie
assez logique
le coutour b1 pour être meilleur que
coûte le couteau b2 et on verra plus
tard
on verra plus tard on a vraiment guitare
si on ne peut pas l'expliquer tout de
suite sur être aux deux variantes alors
en attendant on est comme ça on attend
on est comme ça va bien on va bien les
versions détour oui on peut juste leur
montrer une deuxième fois donc les tours
qui ferait un voilà une version donc
tombé 1
ton père au lieu de la tour donc la
tourbe est un qui devrait être sur ses
seins et la tour c 2 qui devrait être
sur la case beytout alors voilà juste
mettre des petites flèches pour les
tours tactique et ça et on revient la
position de la partie à la base de voile
et en bois petit changement tôt h6 donc
la logique de topalov donc on voit qui
combine saas etc des jolis coussins on
peut dire à julie coût des chèques
jean-luc on combine à la fois défense et
attaque
voilà donc ça c'est parfait cette tour
et c'est sans doute la meilleure case
pour cette tombe finalement c'est le h6
pour l'instant c'est la case que la
tourache si c'est que la tour noire de
rejoindre est lié damas six donc ça y
est merci trani qu'étant à 6 fait
pression un peu sur ses six bon c'est
pas grave c'est bien défendu un peu sur
a7 et surtout contre la casse besset ton
qui menacent trang de jouer tomber cette
wii ou simplement attaque en attaquant
la dame noire et pénétrations ensuite on
prendrait le pion à 7 et là c'est
terminé
voilà et puis il n'a pas peur du coup
ces cinq aussi un petit coup qui
pourrait être qui est quand même une
menace directe à on va le voir en cas de
ces cinq week et encore il faut quand
même analyser ce coup qui est vraiment
un goût c'est pas rien puisque la
tourache six attaques la dame blonde
coulon très attention ce genre de coups
puisque ce sont souvent les amateurs
voient pas les coudes comme ça l'est oui
là c'est clair qu'ils en amateur peut
tomber dans le piège et
c'est ça on peut oublier parce que c'est
les coups l'on sait les couvents c'est
les coûts de traverse en plus la vidéo
on voit facilement les colonnes on a
l'habitude et on voit moins souvent les
traverses ça arrive surtout en blitz
alors évidemment c'est le genre de coups
qu'on oublie facilement et bien dans ce
cas là alors sur ces sacs peut-être
qu'un coup comme damien b 7 par exemple
autour bessette on peut encore je
tombais 7 on peut jouer autour des 7
c'est un peu compliqué quand même pour
baisser puisque ça laisserait une tour
active quand même mais ça laisse la dame
en prix aux contrôles adam adverse
voilà donc ça complique un petit peu le
jeu peut-être tout ouïe tour de cette tv
set alors quand même actif puisque si
les noirs accepte les changes
après tout reprend dame est bien le pion
des cinq as des soucis oui mais la tour
à 6 peut prendre à deux comme un bateau
raciste peut prendre un à deux donc
c'est donnant-donnant il peut y avoir
beaucoup des changes la tour prend l'air
sur le dessin c'est compliqué mais je
pense que c'est pas dans l'intérêt des
baignoire de jojo position c'est pour ça
qu'il a ce pion attention soutien des
cinq temps le fouga de manière active
c'est pour ça que c'est un cavalier
tiendra pas longtemps tout à fait alors
pour ces sept de topalov sur damas il a
choisi pour ces sept et non pas de jouer
cette histoire d'amour avec ses 5 qui
était quand même une combinaison qu'il
fallait calculer mais taux plein
bizarrement d'ailleurs choisi le coup le
plus plu le plus solide il ne veut pas
encore échanger des pièces aussi donc
quand il faut tourner cette île est vite
détourné cette désagréable et vite voilà
il est vite mais il n'empêche pas tour
des huit ils empêchent la tombe et 8
échecs mais il ya quand même pénétration
oui mais il a réussi à placer sa tour
sur 1,6 donc il peut placer son roi sur
h7 tout en gardant une droite cet te
regardant une tour actifs sur la colonne
alors que cette tour est toujours actif
voilà tout à fait et maintenant joli
coup là encore une fois de kramnik on
voit qu'il a joué pas mal de coulans
damas trois et on voit que cette dame
est allée en e2 ensuite à l'italie en a
six et maintenant elle se retrouve en a
trois pourquoi et bien tout simplement
pour venir sur la case et fuite encore
en coulant puisque to ride hamissi il
menacerait tout simplement un échec très
certainement soit en fuite soient ans
j'ai vite il veut rentrer dans le camp
des noirs il veut rentrer dans le camp
tout simplement être posée de commencer
à faire des échecs sur le roi avec des
gros soucis en perspective et beaucoup
de calculs donc on voit voilà on voit
très bien ici l'idée l'idée de
chroniques sur ce coup damas trois qui
paraît curieux mais non on vise la case
des fuites tout simplement et bien
topalov se laisse pas évidemment
impressionné est tombé cette voie là ils
y vont mais ok si tu viens en fuite est
bien chez change ta tour alors une
possibilité pour les blancs ici aurait
été de jouer le coutour à 8 ans kramnik
voilà voilà un coût possible
là on enlève ses possibilités des
changes de tours et on menace toujours
d'un v8 au littoral 8 sort était la
solution donc utile pour
on fait la pression plus sur le pion
voilà pour garder pour garder les pièces
pour aider un peu plus de pièces égard
disposions sur l'a7
donc mon s'était toujours pas facile
mais on est quand même on a quand même
un petit avantage de référence aux
questions à traiter au 8e tour à 8 sa
valeur un peu mieux mais là je crois que
l'on peut dire que kramnik se trompent
voilà juste un petit pont a précisé bon
tout à l'heure j'avais expliqué d'une
nuance entre coups de tours et un autre
donc là si ça avait été l'hôte couteau
qui avait été joué donc cette touriste
eswi ici voilà exactement la tour c'est
un séance français de donc cette petite
nuance plus tard aura son importance
je préfère en reparler d'accord avant de
le repréciser plus tard on va le revoir
donc ici dames et fuite
et ça ça ensemble donc un peu moins fort
puisque la tour était quand même sur la
huitième rangée avec un roi qui est pas
loin
alors il quand même été mieux être
cachés en a huit contrôlant une très
belle rangée dans le camp ennemi et non
kramnik accepte les changes de tours en
jouant dans les fuites donc total se
prive pas pour prendre pour dame prend
pour et maintenant c'est là qu'on peut
dire que topalov va inverser le cours du
jeu wii topalov donc va inverser le
cours du jeu dans cette position en
jouant donc
en essayant d'attaquer sur la colonne
âge sur l'océan de la fameuse colonne h
donc on avait dit ce n'était pas facile
d'attaquer mais ça y est on parle pas
trouvé tout de suite maintenant c'est
possible d'aller recettes et voilà ça
les lada maintenant menace tout
simplement devenir h scène et de faire
un échec très pénible en hd très pénible
et encore une fois
mais force est aussi puisqu'il faut
quand même donc toute petite halle
précision de chroniques et grosse
différence petit à précision mais pas
tant que ça quand même si kramnik là on
voit quand même qu'il a des ressources
il a quand même des ressources la taille
de minorités a porté ses fruits le pion
c6 comme on l'indiqué est faible et donc
chronique va quand même peu quand même
les sessions hd le pillage de ce n'est
pas la fin de la partie c'est pas la fin
puisque le fou contrôle très bien la
défense durant exactement ce qu'on peut
toujours jouer roi f1 il n'y a pas de
match exactement voilà ça c'est la clé
de la position mais il faut faire
attention puisqu'il y aura quand même un
cavalier échec il peut y avoir beaucoup
de choses donc il joue comme ces huit
hommes c'est 8 à attaquer la fable est
donc très joli coup ici de défense on
peut dire c'est un coup d'attaqué de
défense à la fois ont fait pression sur
ses six avec la tour et avec la dame et
en même temps on a un oeil aussi sur le
pion f5 très important puisque ce pion 9
5 qui serait pris avec échec va un peu
obligé les noirs de garder la date dans
le coin à la défense après damas tanks
kramnik jouer le très joli couple de
défense bref voilà très joli coup
puisque d'après h2 et contrer tout
simplement par un dame par f5 qu'il a
par contre donnerait un avantage ou
blanc exactement
on peut le voir d'ailleurs d'un proche
d'eux évidemment dans prend f5 avec
échec il faudrait rejouer
par exemple le roi a ensuite voilà tout
simplement y aurait au moins un
perpétuel des échecs échec échec donc là
les blancs au moins au moins le nul au
môle perpétuelle mais probable un peu
aussi peut-être prendre un prêt de
reprendre le 4 avec des pièces quand
même plus active faut faire attention et
parce qu'il ya la tour derrière aussi
mais bon voilà enfin si la tension s'est
compliqué alors damage cinq rois f1 donc
pour empêcher d'en prend avec échec pour
prendre le pion f5 en échange
donc c'est un mauvais marché puisque le
sous-pull encore loin et pourtant celui
ci parce que celui ci quand même tient
le clavier au centre donc taux peuvent
rentrer dans une autre variante donc
que kramnik à calculer évidemment
cavaliers des deux échecs au roi et là
quasiment la suite va être forcé l'un on
peut pas on peut pas venir à angers 1
puisque évident sur roy g1
vous l'avez tous vu il ya un matin je
vous laisse réfléchir deux secondes d'un
proche de tout échec et mat
voilà maintenant puisque le roi ne peut
pas sortir à cause du cavalier ici donc
on peut pas déjà revenir sur la case
bien en sortir est de gaz soit 2,2 soit
20 et là faut pas se tromper
faut pas se tromper si on vend 2 abc on
va 2 c'est le problème
on va le voir par rapport à la partie de
crâne hic c'est que en veut deux ici on
ne permet pas aux fous de se replier et
d'avoir une action sur ces balades sur
cette diagonale empêche le foot voilà on
empêche le fou de jouer qui il est
complètement pris sous on voit bien
qu'il est enfermé il est muselée il est
muselée donc il va être pris il va être
pris le risque est pris donc alors
kramnik joue bon coup ils ont eu droit
eux il a fallait le voir alors je suis
allé le voir attaque le cavalier encore
encore à ça encore une fois un tout
petit retour n'a rien on va revenir à
cette position là donc là on vient de
voir que topalov vient de jouer cavalier
des deux essais la course et c'est là où
la tour ces deux auraient peut-être été
si la tour avec des lacets c'était plus
pareil exactement changer un petit peu
la situation
mais quand même la pression non aux
réformes ce côté là c'est quand même pas
facile
oui mais dans ces cas là les noirs
auraient dû faire un choix là peut-être
avec la tour en c2 le cavaly ne pouvait
pas venir dans que sur la case
les deux et six classes des deux ils
seront payés il aurait fallu jouer autre
chose se replier c'est pas forcément la
solution donc qu'à valider deux
effectivement est possible un peu la
petite différence dont crois important
est la taupe avait choisi un coup comme
kbc 4 voilà donc la vallée s'est gâté
permettre défend l'option 6,6 tout
simplement tout simplement empêche la
tour ici d'avoir accès aux pions c6 et
n'en est défendue par la tour contre la
dame
oui et puis maintenant on va essayer
donc de prendre ce fameux pions ce
fameux virage qui on voit toute façon le
problème pour les blancs c'est que ce
cavalier plus actif que sous ces fous
est un peu mort où ils allaient noire
les noirs commencent à 12 d'inverser la
tendance dans le cou de kramnik fouet
fin voilà toujours alors je garde un
pion sur le jeu garde pendant un oeil
sur le fcn est maintenant en jouant
fouet st j'attaque le cavalier
maintenant voilà maintenant le problème
c'est que le roi va être un peu tout nu
une fois que ce four a disparu il pourra
pas trop se défendre elle le fameux
retenue donc c'est vrai que roy là va
être un petit peu à découvert mais d'où
le joli coup de topalov mais bon topalov
white au palace dont il veut plus roi
soit à découvert et des fours sont pures
et 5 pour continuer la tacc par dan rush
de voilà tout est très difficile voilà
un petit coup 30 il maintenant je
protège f5 avec ma tour donc il ya plus
d'un an prend f5 et maintenant c'est
plus un jeu est mort je vais le prendre
au prochain coup quoi qu'il arrive
voilà l'idée évidemment de topalov c'est
quand même très très bien joué
pour elle si ce très joli coup face
toujours tragique
à jouer les coups les plus précis les
seuls coups même et seul et maintenant
crâne il se trompe pas il prend tout
simplement le cavalier et après pions en
cavalier on reprend de la tour et ça y
est c'est l'heure pour les noirs d'un
proche d'eux et là problème maintenant
pour les blancs on voit bien que les
blancs mais non c'est eux qui sont
passés en défense puisque ce roi ici et
quand même mieux protégés que celui ci
qui est quand même en plein courant
d'air
on voit bien qu'il n'ya pas beaucoup de
plomb autour de lui pour le protéger il
ya la dame qui va commencer à faire des
échecs soit engins soi même plutôt en h1
et on voit bien qu'il ya un problème sur
les cases blanches voilà donc il ya un
souci mais de l'autre côté bon les
blancs quand même la possibilité de
tenir puisque de leur côté les noirs
doivent garder leur tour à la défense du
pur 5 et 7 tours et passive donc une
dame simplement pour attaquer roi ça
suffit pas pour gagner
à noter qu'une erreur pour les blancs
seraient simplement de jouer le coutour
en qui on galère bon ce que je gagne
avion à cause de la fourchette en
lâchant à cause de la fourchette
effectivement dame échec
voilà échec au roi il faut par l échec
et il ya aussi la tour qui est en prise
de la dame
alors tu apprends h2 donc la chronique
se trompent pas il prend pas le pion
évidemment alors que oui non il ya
simplement régi des petits bruits qui
nous dérange
c'était quoi ça ses bruits ses bruits
non je ne sais pas trop demander à
séverine donc on verra ça plus tard
alors donc ici re deux voies la logique
répression d'être alcoolique sacré vous
dans tous les sens alors 3e 2 donc la
logique en quoi de zinc ou
prophylactiques et leurs échecs on évite
les chèques quoi tout simplement dans
l'achat quand même on protège ses six et
en même temps on va venir en f3 faire en
échec tour c5 et la topalov peut prendre
la nulle probablement avec damas trois
puisqu'il faut garder le contact avec le
ps 2 oui mais il va essayer
meva corps essaie de gagner on va voir
la suite quand même d'un essaim
d'abeilles un pardon oui ils se
rapprochent menaces d'emprunt de vivre
il veut prendre le pion le pion à 2 il
faut le défendre c'est ce qui se fait un
point de plus et il défend son plus
récent 5 et en même temps effectivement
tout à fait il défend son pur et c'est
donc il va pouvoir libérer sa tour pour
revenir à mater le roi alors encore une
fois une fourchette importante c'est que
si les blancs prennent le pion c6 après
d'amener un fou dans cette position il y
aurait il n'y aurait pas encore
peut-être pas encore dame b 5 échecs
drame humain prend à deux on peut
prendre le pion d'abord on peut prendre
le pion à d'abord et après je vais le
ku'damm des cinq tours on revient on
revient avec les blancs dans ce cas là
mais il ya le problème du roi qui est en
l'air mais ça aurait été possible oui ça
semble tout à fait possible pour les
blancs de prendre ce pion mais kramnik a
choisi une autre une autre variante il a
choisi il veut pas aller ou pas donato
pas fait la moindre chance de passer son
pion à peut-être ils avaient peur de
ceux qui ont personnellement après le
couteau qu'on saisisse d'un programme
des 5 est quand même très dangereux
parce qu'on est obligé de jouer tour
cedar des cinq échecs évidemment ça
attaque la tour mais on peut revenir en
défense avec la trop on peut revenir en
défense mais il faut quand même trouver
des coups après le coutour à six tours à
six parce que la tour c quatre et cloud
et la tour est loué en menace tout
reprend à 2 suivi d'un match voilà et la
dame protège le pion f5 toujours très
important exactement donc là comment
paris sa et bien tout simplement il
faudrait empêcher les chèques
c'est je pense qu'il faut convoquer faut
qu'on joue un coup comme dans ses 5 ans
l'opposition faut jouer à coup comme
d'hab c5 et c7 jean-luc il va y avoir
trop prendre deux chèques
il va y avoir tout reprendre à zéro vis
d'une pénétration de la dame noire oui
mais dans ces cas là on pourra prendre
le pion m5
alors voyons ça dams et serge non ça
serait ce serait une erreur et on prend
à 2,3 et femmes à nantes reprend à deux
échecs roi f1 et maintenant on pourrait
faire tours échelles profitant du fait
que la torre cloud et 3g deux mois j'ai
deux trois ou deux est-ce que sur roy g2
jean vu que j'ai peur on va voir roger 2
il y aurait encore un échec ici
c'est compliqué c'est compliqué mais
yahia surtout d'amd qui est déjà payant
qui force la tête un sacrifice passion
ça serait peut-être maths parce que
échec l'idée c'est que sur dan c6 jean
luc touly n'attaque plus puristes 5 est
donc maintenant d'un bien et voilà le
roi et au piège exactement
camatte imparable parce qu'il n'ya plus
le ya plus le petit échec qui sauvent et
qui sauvait la baraque donc très
attention il faut faire très attention
donc il peut pas prendre le pion voilà
il faut pas prendre le pion c'est
vraiment dangereux et il doit donc jouer
damas ici donc il joue effectivement
damas 6 notre ami kramnik protégeant
pion à 2 mai et ça fait peur parce que
là d'annoncer 8 était bien placé à
l'attaqué f5 et la dame
on va voir que kramnik a tout vu il a
pas peur on va voir qu'après d'enlever
deux échecs roi f1 topalov n'a pas
d'autre choix que de faire des échecs
dans bay un échec
roy eu deux dents b 2 échecs wife
kramnik propose nul mais non pas la veut
encore essayer de gagner tous âges 6
attention ils menacent de venir en chien
voire même en h2 avec la dame ici pour
menacer un math hilton le pur f5 mais
encore une fois une fourchette toujours
des fourchettes sur ton problème c'est
qu'il ya tout simplement d'amener un
échec
wei sonde à tourcoing 25 évidemment il
ya tant d un échec non puis il ya des
menaces de maths surtout jean luc il
faut faire attention
donc en fait chronique joue dam des
trois voilà il n'est ce pas au noir le
temps de jouer tout rage 2 puisque dans
ce cas là ion et d'un prof 5 avec un
esprit perpétuelle tout simplement sur
le roi et demi donc topalov essaient
encore de couvre les cases blanches
comme détroit pour y jouer 6 yyuu g6
topaloff
il veut il maintenant il ya plus les
cinq donc qu'il ya une menace il ya une
menace de tournage deux ou deux tours h1
avec une pénétration de la dame ensuite
sur le casa et un math un math rapide
mais kramnik évidemment empêche sa dame
b 3 propose un échange de dames et après
ici topalov aurait pu jouer par exemple
dame un échec menace qu'a la chronique
serait venu sur la case eux deux
simplement il adel b 3 qui propose
évidemment un échange mais qui menace
aussi d'un lasse de faire des échecs au
revoir donc il n'a pas le choix
les deux camps sont quand même assez
assez dégarni et leur dire que total a
fait une combinaison nul voilà topalov
se prépare pour les matchs de départage
voilà on va voir sa très jolie commune
entre monde nul quand même tous rachats
donc ils proposent pas nulles ils
l'imposent l'imposent voilà donc ça
c'est la technique de topalov tour échec
il n'y a pas le choix ils iront jusqu'au
bout un seul courage et 2 et maintenant
on sacrifie la tour tout simplement avec
tourage deux échecs quand je les
sacrifices de tours il faut évidemment
prendre la tour on n'a pas le choix
voilà si le roi bouge c'est dame prend
f2 échec et mat
le fameux baiser de la mort fameux
baiser de la mort décidément reprend h2
et maintenant c'est nul avec d'un prof
de échec au roi roi chez un échec
perpétuel avec d'un médecin voilà en
effet un rouage deux dames f2 on va
répéter trois fois la position très
jolie attaque défense dans cette partie
oui entrer jusqu'à pâques défense bon
match on va dire un match qui se termine
par une égalité 6 partout alors avec
cette fameuse partie par forfait avec
cette fameuse partie par forfait un
échec perpétuel à la fin pour montrer
quand même
le bras de fer la polémique le bras de
fer les boxeurs évidemment les deux
combattants de l'échiquier et donc donc
là les pronostics
maintenant pour le départage c'est
vraiment tendu vont être très serré la
main tendue c'est vraiment tendu la fidh
et n'a pas répondu à la réclamation de
kramnik de faire rejouer cette cinquième
partie donc pour la fidh et la solution
serait que le crâne qui gagne mais la
seule solution maintenant c'est que
crâne y gagnent si on veut avoir un
champion du monde incontestable parce
que s'ils topalov l'emportent au
départage
il y aura toujours se prendre une
cinquième partie et alors ça va pas
résoudre le problème de l'unification du
titre mondial
bon on va voir la suite
est ce que ton palop va réussir à gagner
et on va avoir encore des soucis pendant
des années avant que la réunification
soient claires et nettes mais en
attendant bon ben ya encore des matchs
des partages kramnik peut encore
l'emporter ce qui l'a par contre
mettrait tout le monde d'accord je pense
que là on sera d'accord
oui là c'est classique ramener gagne bon
c'est vrai qu'il a eu deux ans de
passage à vide les deux dernières années
mais il s'est préparé pour ce match
il est en forme et à noter quand même
chronique a battu kasparov un beau
champion qu'il a tenu face à l'écrou ou
même si c'était un peu de justesse mais
il a tenu
il n'y a pas eu de problème nos règles
non c'est vrai que c'est serra et et que
là s'il bat topalov même un warm plus
même s'ils gagnent au départage grammy
qui même dans le match il aura gagné
puisqu'il mène 6-5 en fait sur
l'échiquier et avec une partie avec les
blancs qu'on lui a enlevé
non ce serait mérité bon enfin on n'en
est pas là mais en tout cas voilà très
gros match terminant sur ce score égal
avec une partie par forfait accordé à
topalov très gros match dès départage
dix années qui s'annoncent tout à fait
tendues en partie rapide et bien ce sera
fera l'objet de notre prochaine émission
qui sera champion du monde unifié
topalov avec un problème de légitimité
du goût de cette cinquième partie au
kram nick champion du monde est
contestable et bien on verra ça lors de
la prochaine émission merci jean luc
nancy stéphane à bientôt et à bientôt
oh